[Musique]
l'hebdo politique bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous politique du dimanche soir
sur radio sensations en association avec
tv 118 épisode 209 mon invité ce soir et
la sénatrice des yvelines martha de
sidrac
[Musique]
les politiques
martha décidera bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes la sénatrice l ère des yvelines
habitant à saint germain en laye vous
devenez en 2008 maire-adjointe dans
cette ville en charge de la vie scolaire
et de la petite enfance en 2014 vous
devenez première adjointe en charge des
solidarités du logement et de l'emploi
en 2010 est vous êtes élu au sénat sur
la liste de gérard larcher et depuis
2021 vous êtes aussi la présidente de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines vous
êtes aussi la présidente de la mission
locale de saint germain en laye ch alors
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 vous avez décidé de soutenir xavier
bertrand qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
faire ce choix et pas par exemple celui
de valérie pécresse ici dans son fief d
ib non c'est qu'avec elle compte de
nombreux soutiens alors c'est une très
bonne question et c'est une question que
l'on me pose souvent ces derniers temps
pour les raisons que vous avez évoqué je
suis yvelinoise implanté dans mon
territoire j'aime beaucoup mon
département et aujourd'hui nous avons
cinq candidats qui se présentent à ce
congrès et l'air moi j'ai fait le choix
de xavier bertrand puisque c'est
quelqu'un que je suis depuis quelques
temps déjà dont j'ai fait la
connaissance depuis
un certain nombre de mois maintenant un
parcours que je trouve très intéressant
une détermination sans faille et une
clarté dans ses propositions qui me
parlent et qui je pense parle à beaucoup
de français au delà de des territoires
que l'on peut représenter les uns et les
autres je trouve que valérie pécresse a
également beaucoup de talent et pour ne
rien vous cacher ce n'est pas du tout un
scoop ce que je vais vous dire mais moi
je fais partie de ceux qui plaident pour
qu'il puisse y avoir une entente entre
valérie pécresse et xavier bertrand mais
quoi qu'il en soit on voit bien que nous
avons une belle équipe de france qui se
profile et moi j'espère que à la tête de
cette belle équipe de france il y aura
bien évidemment que ça vieillit bertrand
depuis quand est ce que vous le
connaissez vous allez leur eau depuis
maintenant plus plus de deux ans plus
depuis plus de deux ans puisque vous
savez nous les parlementaires nous
sommes coutumiers de rencontres avec
différents élus différents grands élus
il est président de région à ce titre là
j'ai pu observer un petit peu un certain
nombre d'actions y compris sur des
sujets que moi je porte au sénat que ce
soit autour d'eux des sujets sociaux
vous avez évoqué j'avais été première
adjointe sur ces sujets là donc j'ai une
vraie sensibilité sociale nous sommes
dans un pays quand même assez fracturé
un pays dans lequel nous avons toujours
cette france des gilet jaune qui est là
qu il ne faut surtout pas oublier et je
trouve que xavier bertrand est un homme
qui part aussi à cette france parfois
oubliés des élites
alors au moment où nous enregistrons
cette émission de débats ont déjà eu
lieu entre les cinq candidats à
l'investiture et l'air pour l'élection
présidentielle xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse michel barnier eric ciotti et
philippe juvin qu'est ce que vous avez
retenu pour l'instant de ces échanges
alors moi j'ai retenu qu'en réalité on
voit bien que les valeurs de la droite
sont toujours là sont toujours présentes
on voit bien que malgré des différences
ici ou là sur tel ou tel sujet non pas
sur le fond mais plutôt sur la manière
de les mettre en oeuvre ils peuvent
apparaître
donc moi ce que je retiens
essentiellement d'abord c'est une vraie
volonté de rassemblement en le sang chez
les 5 vous avez pu observer comme moi
qu'il n'y a eu à aucun moment
véritablement d'attac d'un je dirais de
l'un d'eux vis-à-vis d'un des autres
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est très
fort pour notre famille politique ce
rassemblement que l'on souhaite tous
deuxième sujet les valeurs de la droite
sont là sont réels avec de vraies
propositions de la part des cinq
candidats ont peut être plus d'accord
avec certaines propositions s'il
retrouvait plus dans d'autres mais le
fait est que les cinq candidats que nous
avons aujourd'hui en
préparation - en tant que tel présente
en fait
des valeurs dans lesquelles je pense que
la grande famille de la droite peut se
retrouver aisément xavier bertrand a
pourtant longtemps hésité à participer à
ce système de départager ce qu'il avait
vraiment le choix alors en réalité il
n'était pas pour une primaire ouverte
vous savez vous avez suivi comme moi ce
qui a pu se passer la précédente
primaire que nous avons vécu dans la
famille de la droite on s'est déchiré et
ce déchirement nous a valu en fait une
certaine dispersion et une certaine
désaffection de nos militants à un
moment donné car incompréhension donc
c'était plutôt ça qu'il ne souhaitait
pas et c'était contre cela qu'ils ne
fassent était dense est ce type de
primaire qu'il ne souhaitait pas
à faire enfin voilà être candidat en
revanche dès lors que les militants ont
choisi le congrès il n'y avait plus
aucun obstacle à ce que bien évidemment
ça a toujours été un homme de droite
c'est quelqu'un qui a effectivement
quitté le parti à un moment donné mais
qui n'a jamais fait en partie à lui il y
à la manufacture évidemment tout le
monde connaît la manufacture mais qui
est plus un qui n'est pas un parti
politique en tant que tel don qui n'a
jamais renié ses valeurs de droite ça
reste un homme de droite et du centre
bien évidemment mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas moi je fais
partie de ceux qui se réjouissent de le
voir revenir au sein des élèves nous
allons maintenant rentrer dans le coeur
du projet de xavier bertrand un projet
intitulé nous france alors il repose sur
trois axes majeurs le premier
l'instauration d'une république des
territoires
alors nous devons donc comprendre
qu'actuellement la république est trop
centralisée trop parisienne le centre et
doit comprendre ah oui je crois qu on
est nombreux à faire ce constat là
aujourd'hui nous avons une espèce de de
centralisme exacerbée par tous lui a le
mérite de vraiment pointé ce ce défaut
que nous avons aujourd'hui dans la
gestion de notre pays et moi en tant que
sénatrice je ne peux pas vous dire que
je suis contre bien au contraire tout
cela me parle tout cela évoque ce que
l'on entend sur le terrain tous les
jours de la part de nos élus locaux de
la part de nos mères parfois on a des
décisions qui sont plaquées
véritablement dans les territoires
qu'ils viennent d'en haut qui vient de
paris
et que les élus locaux ne comprennent
pas ne comprennent pas non pas forcément
parce qu' il n'aurait pas les codes pour
le comprendre mais simplement parce que
parfois ces décisions là ne sont pas
adaptées au territoire qui est le leur
et de ce fait je pense que cet axe là
dans son programme est un axe fort
qu'ils méritent véritablement que l'on
regarde de près ce qui lie mais puisque
c'est un volet assez large il parle
d'environnement il parle de l'école il
part d'éducation de la manière dont tout
cela doit pouvoir diffuser dans les
territoires et il me semble que c'est
quelqu'un qui de nos comptes de nos cinq
candidats celui qui en parle le mieux
alors il souhaite mettre en oeuvre
notamment la réforme du conseiller
territorial lors cette réforme avait été
votée en 2010 sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy
mais elle n'avait jamais été appliquée
après l'arrivée au pouvoir de françois
hollande dans l'idée c'est que les
conseillers départementaux se retrouve
aussi au conseil régional lors cela
engendrerait selon vous plus de
cohérence dans les diffusions wii et
plus de compréhension en fait justement
ça va aussi dans le sens de la
décentralisation puisque vous voyez ça
créerait des élus en fait qui serait une
strate beaucoup plus proche du terrain
est beaucoup plus au fait des réalités
des terrains et des spécificités de
chaque territoire est ce que cette
réforme vous permettrait aussi de faire
des économies il faudrait semblablement
bien évidemment puisque l'idée en
réalité c'est lorsque nous fusionnons
d'une certaine manière ces conseillers
c'est qu'à un moment donné en termes de
nombre c'est c'est mathématique qui
seront évidemment moins nombreux et de
ce fait incertain une certaine économie
est évidemment attendu de ce fait alors
exhaler bertrand souhaite faire sauter
le verrou centralisateur parisien
beaucoup de maires l'ont réclamé lors du
son troisième congrès de l'association
des maires de france aujourd'hui il faut
faire plus confiance au maire leur
donner plus de compétences aux mairies
aux collectivités locales aux
territoires plus globalement donner plus
de compétences alors moi je dis plus de
compétences signifie aussi plus de
responsabilités signifie aussi avec
quels moyens donc il ne faut pas d
déconnectez tous ces points qui vont
ensemble donc oui je pense qu'un maire
et c'est ma conviction intime et celui
qui est le plus à même de savoir ce qui
se passe chez lui ce qui se passe dans
sa proximité immédiate et donc ils
peuvent être le plus à même de répondre
à un certain nombre de demandes on l'a
vu même dans le cadre de la pandémie la
crise sanitaire qui était en fait un
phénomène mondial on a bien vu qu'en
france en réalité ce qui était
précisément à la manoeuvre sur le pont
24 heures sur 24 avant tout c'était les
maires mais en revanche on niveau
rappelez-vous le sénat s'était battu
pour cela au niveau responsabilité il
faut que les maires et les élus locaux
soient parfaitement au fait de qu'une
compétence eli est souvent une certaine
responsabilité il faut que nous soyons
là pour pouvoir porter aussi cette voie
là et lorsqu'on dit compétences et
responsabilités il faut aussi leur
donner les moyens d'exercer précisément
toutes ses compétences le mieux possible
au service de nos administrés donc oui
moi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
ça va dans le bon sens évidemment et je
trouve que xavier bertrand a raison de
proposer en tout cas de d'affirmer cela
mais évidemment cela suppose comme je
vous disais que nous soyons vigilants en
matière de responsabilité et en matière
de moyens les moyens que nous donnons à
nos communes et donc aux élus locaux il
ya un autre thème sur lequel le
président et aux français
particulièrement investi c'est l'énergie
il souhaite que donc arrêter totalement
le développement des énergies éoliennes
or pourtant c'est une énergie
renouvelable devrait pas continuer à la
développer alors vous savez aujourd'hui
on sort de la coop 26 qui s'est tenue il
n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
malheureusement avec une certaine
déception de la part d'un certain nombre
de daube servat teurs et de partenaires
impliqués dans cette coop 26 et on
observe aujourd'hui notre combat c'est
contre les gaz à émission 20
léger us comme on dit et nous avons
aussi en france une énergie nucléaire
qui est décarbonée qui nous permet
d'avoir une certaine autonomie une
certaine souveraineté sur notre énergie
il ne faut surtout pas la fragiliser
tels que cela a pris le chemin moi je
suis assez content des dernières
déclarations du président de la
république écrit en mais qui en réalité
ne font que confirmer ce que xavier
bertrand dit depuis des mois et des
semaines et donc pour revenir à votre
question sur les éoliennes il ne faut
pas mettre en contradiction enfin et en
opposition les différentes énergies dans
notre mix énergétique
nous avons besoin de toutes ces énergies
là en revanche sur les éoliennes je
crois qu'il a tout à fait raison d'être
aussi affirmatif et de dire qu'il ne
faut pas que nous les déployons
aujourd'hui de manière inconsidérée pour
une raison toute simple moi je suis
présidente du groupe économie circulaire
au sénat et je travaille c'est justement
sur ce sujet là et vous savez que le
temps de vie des éoliennes c'est 20 30
ans en moyenne et là nous sommes dans un
cycle en réalité où les premières
éoliennes commence à être en fin de vie
et donc on se repose la question de
quelle manière on continue à investir
dans les éoliennes ou pas en revanche
lorsqu'on est en fin de vie d'un outil
il faut se poser la question est-il
réemployables recyclables comment est ce
que il impacte l'environnement fortement
et c'est là où on se rend compte qu'en
réalité l'éolienne est encore un outil
enfin encore une énergie renouvelable
qui mérite qu'on s'y intéresse d'un
point de vue cycle de vie d'un point de
vue impact environnemental global c'est
ce que je fais aujourd'hui au sénat et
c'est pour ça sans vouloir opposer
aucune énergie vis-à-vis d'une autre il
est fondamental est véritablement
nécessaire de connaître quel est
l'impact global environnemental des
énergies renouvelables et spécifiquement
des éoliennes puisque vous savez que les
éoliennes ont aussi des impacts sur nos
défenses en les militaires aussi on ne
souhaite pas avoir des éoliennes à
proximité d'un certain nombre de nos
bases et c'est parce que ça peut
brouiller des radars ça peut prendre ou
y ait des communications et donc à ce
titre là l'éolien n'est pas neutre dans
notre paysage et vous savez aussi que
vous avez des petites éoliennes or
aujourd'hui on s'oriente de plus en plus
deere de très grosses éoliennes avec
donc tous ces impacts qui pourrait y
avoir pour l'environnement pour rebondir
sur le nucléaire maintenant xavier
bertrand avait annoncé notamment l'or
lors des débats que sa une une de ses
premières mesures serait d'appeler le
patron d'edf pour construire dix
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires
supplémentaires et mais elle macro
annoncé la même chose le mardi 9
novembre sans préciser le nombre exact
de nouveaux réacteurs ce que le
président de la république vous a
surpris finalement c'était pas vraiment
écouté du quinquennat non c'est moi je
me suis dit ce qu'il a écouté les débats
il a écouté ce que nos candidats de la
droite proposait donc il s'en inspire
bon après chacun interprétera cela comme
il le souhaitera sur le fond de la
question pourrait être sérieuse dans ma
réponse je dirais que c'est us est une
bonne chose moi personnellement je crois
que comme j'ai pu vous le dire le
nucléaire aujourd'hui en france on ne
peut pas s'en passer et quand je dis en
france pas qu'en france nous pouvons
aussi envisagé il faut qu'on le fasse et
des choses qui que des pays nous
demandent l'exporter on a un savoir
faire qu'il ne faut surtout pas perdre
il y va de notre innovation de notre
recherche en fusion et en fission
puisque la le nucléaire aujourd'hui
c'est de la fiction mais vous savez que
nous avons aussi le projet iter qui est
en france aujourd'hui 34 états sont
concernés de fusion en fait de l'atome
et je crois que c'est tout cela va dans
le bon sens pour cette énergie de demain
et donc moi je plaide pour que notre
mixte notre mix énergétique ne se passe
pas du nucléaire au contraire
deuxième axe majeur du programme de
xavier bertrand il plaide pour une
société du travail il veut que chaque
salarié touche au moins 1500 euros par
mois c'est l'état qui mettra la main à
la poche pour compléter le salaire des
français qui touchent moins de 2000
euros par mois dans la mesure est estimé
à 5 milliards d'euros par xavier
bertrand certains disent que c'est
démagogique d'autre que ça existe déjà
que ça s'appelle la prime d'activité
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez alors
moi je trouve que la mesure qu'il
propose est tout à fait intéressante et
puis en sémantique c'est important aussi
appelé sa prime prime du travail c'est
bien parce que c'est vraiment dans la
volonté
2 que le travail soit le plus
rémunérateur possible et que sans
opposer cela aux allocations aux aides
que l'on peut avoir par ailleurs mais
que ce soit avant tout le premier
vecteur pour nos ménages en fait un et
pour la classe moyenne en france donc
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne mesure
c'est une mesure sociale mais aussi
économique puisque dès lors que l'on
donne un peu plus de pouvoir d'achat aux
français il est évident que cela va
avoir une incidence aussi sur l'économie
sur la consommation sur le pouvoir
d'achat donc tout cela est en
corrélation en cohérence par rapport
donc à son programme dans lequel comme
on l'a évoqué déjà dans nos propos
liminaire on voit bien la fibre sociale
du candidat à bertrand or avant l'été
2022 xavier bertrand veut organiser une
grande conférence sociale sur le niveau
des salaires à quoi servirait tel
concrètement cette conférence je pense
que aujourd'hui le travail en france et
est très taxée en fait un don qu'il faut
qu'on libère un tout petit peu ce ce
pouvoir de production ce pouvoir de
2oc de des rémunérations comme on vient
d'en parler et il me semble qu'il faut
que nous ayons un grand débat un grand
débat non pas peau parce que des
solutions beaucoup y ont déjà réfléchi
on voit déjà nos candidats qui propose
un certain nombre de solutions mais pour
que cela puisse fonctionner pour que
cela puisse se mettre en place il faut
que l'ensemble des partenaires soit
autour de la table et c'est dans ce sens
là qu'il faut qu'il y ait ce débat là de
manière à l'ensemble des intéressés bien
évidemment les représentants des
salariés
bien évidemment les pouvoirs publics
bien évidemment les différentes
animations il faut que tout un chacun
puisse pouvoir s'exprimer et que l'on
pèse et que l'on avance ensemble plutôt
que de nous à un moment donné nous
opposer dans la rue parce qu'il y aura
une manifestation ou dans les salles de
réunion parce qu'on ne pourra pas se
mettre d'accord autour d'une table sur
un accord donc c'est dans ce sens là en
fait c'est véritablement une forme de
concertation une forme de
d'associations de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes sur ces thématiques sur les
heures supplémentaires
maintenant au delà de 35 heures il
souhaite qu'elles soient sans impôts ni
charges c'est le retour du célèbre
travailler plus pour gagner plus on peut
l'appeler comme ça on peut l'appeler
comme ça mais le fait est que oui les 35
heures quand même tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire nous ont plombés
aujourd'hui un donc c'est une réalité il
ne s'agit pas de revenir sur ces 35
heures mais il s'agit en réalité de
permettre de de travailler plus si l on
le souhaite sans pour autant que cela
pénalise les entreprises et bien
évidemment pour que le salarié s'il
retrouve donc c'est du gagnant gagnant
et je trouve en effet que c'est une très
bonne mesure enfin sur la réforme des
retraites et xavier bertrand propose
d'allonger progressivement l'âge du
départ à la retraite d'un trimestre
supplémentaire par an pour atteindre 64
ans en 2030 alors les candidats qui
prône le retour à la retraite à 60 ans
sont totalement des mails démagogique
oui oui personnellement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui imaginez il retraite à 60
ans c'est totalement irréaliste à 60 ans
on est jeune encore aujourd'hui à 60 ans
n'a pas non plus envie en réalité deux
de partir à la retraite on est dans la
force de l'âge de nos jours donc je
crois que c'est totalement irréaliste et
je pense alors évidemment il ya le volet
pénibilité qui l'abordent ailleurs dans
son programme mais voyez moi j'ai 57 ans
aujourd'hui quand on me dit que dans
trois ans potentiellement par rapport à
certains certaines propositions de
candidats moi ça me paraît totalement
surréaliste et en france d'ailleurs on a
un petit peu ce défaut c'est que au delà
d'un certain âge on considère que ben
c'est une force qui dont on n'a plus
besoin or les seniors et on le voit bien
si on fait un parangon nage dans
certains pays d'europe on voit bien qu'à
une véritable corrélation entre l'emploi
des jeunes et l'emploi des seniors plus
vous avez des seniors en activité et
plus le chômage des jeunes est faible et
c'est une réalité que l'on en france on
n'a pas encore percé vraiment perçu et
sur laquelle il est nécessaire de s'y
atteler l'an dernier axe majeur du
candidat berck bertrand le retour de
l'autorité de l'état sur les prisons
d'abord le président de france propose
la création de vingt mille places
supplémentaires
emmanuel macron avait déjà promis la
création de quinze villes parce qu'ils
doivent s'étaler entre 2007 et 2020
107000 auront été créés en 2022 la
construction des 8000 autres places est
prévu lors du prochain quinquennat
xavier bertrand donc veut accélérer avec
20000 places en cinq ans on ne peut plus
attendre aujourd'hui oui on ne peut pas
attendre et mais sert surtout
je ne sais pas si xavier bertrand veut
accélérer simplement ce que je constate
moi c'est que le président de la
république n'a pas tenu sa promesse une
promesse une autre promesse non tenue
donc je crois qu'à un moment donné on ne
peut pas indéfiniment faire confiance à
quelqu'un qui nous a promis un certain
nombre de mesures de réformes qui n'ont
pas été au rendez vous pour
qu'aujourd'hui on ne regarde pas avec
attention les propositions qui sont
faites par xavier bertrand et je trouve
que sa proposition est bonne sa
proposition est ambitieuse et il faudra
s'y atteler oui maintenant tout de suite
parce que ça demande un petit peu de
temps pour créer des places de prison
donc si on ne le fait pas dès le début
d'un mandat en fin d'un quinquennat il
est évident qu'on ne pourra pas tenir
ses promesses à la fin du quinquennat
c'est une mesure qui revient beaucoup à
droite et xavier bertrand la propose
également il faut donc selon eux
plusieurs candidats exclure
systématiquement les étrangers une fois
qu'ils ont purgé des peines de prison
oui moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons différents différents sujets
autour de cela c'est à dire que nous
avons à la fois une immigration illégale
sur laquelle il fait des propositions
très claires et je pense que lorsqu'un
étranger effectivement a purgé sa peine
il n'a plus sa place sur notre
territoire et cela me semble assez
légitime et même réaliste et juste que
cette personne là soit renvoyé dans son
pays encore faut-il que nous france nous
soyons suffisamment fort dans notre dans
notre expression et que nous puissions
nous est un véritable
enfin discours 1 et avec nos
interlocuteurs des pays pourvoyeurs des
migrations je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été aussi une faiblesse de
ce mandat de monsieur macron c'est que à
aucun moment nous n'avons eu
véritablement là la position claire de
la france vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre
de pays pourvoyeurs de
personnes immigrées en fait ici chez
nous sur cette question justement de
l'immigration xavier bertrand souhaite
que l'assemblée nationale établissent
des quotas chaque année en fonction de
quels critères seront fixés ces quotas
c'est il faut il travailler ensemble là
aussi ce sera un sujet éminemment
important puisqu'il est un facteur
humain qui est important aussi donc
c'est un sujet dont il faut se saisir et
donc il faudra gérer évidemment et sur
lequel vous aurez dans les mois à venir
en espérant que ce soit évidemment
xavier bertrand qui soit le candidat de
la droite les propositions turkel des
sons il veut revoir aussi notre système
de frontières il propose une politique
de triple frontier alors aujourd'hui nos
frontières ont trop de lacunes du
constat oui alors il y à différentes
différentes façons de voir là le sujet
bien évidemment les frontières
nationales les frontières de l'europe
entend il ya effectivement un certain
nombre de
2,2 points sur lesquels il faudra que
l'on travaille en effet pour éviter
d'avoir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui bon
déjà il ya le sujet de nos frontières
européennes on voit aujourd'hui ce qui
se passe aussi en pologne c'est un sujet
d'actualité avec une résolution qui est
loin d'être simple et dont on ne va pas
exactement quel sera le résultat une
fille née
donc très clairement oui c'est le sujet
de la frontière simples doubles triples
est un vrai sujet sur lequel il faudra
que l'on se penche très sérieusement
quel que soit le président futur de
notre pays et j'espère que ce sera
xavier bertrand alors vous êtes aussi la
secrétaire de la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat l'actualité robben
est marquée par la crise migratoire qui
se joue à la frontière entre la pologne
et la biélorussie cela vous confirmer
qu'il faut donner plus de moyens et
soutenir encore plus frontex alors oui
frontex mais
je nuancerais mes propos bien sûr
frontex est un outil très important de
l'union européenne mais vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui la pologne qui est membre
de l'union européenne
pour l'instant préfère gérer tout seul
au moment où nous discutons tous a peu
évolué bien évidemment pour pouvoir
garder toujours son discours qui a été
le sien depuis le début de la crise et
les chez elle elle fait ce qu'elle veut
et donc elle veut gérer elle même ses
propres frontières sa crainte et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il il va y avoir
peut-être des débats et des réflexions
autour de frontex parce que frontex
englobe un certain nombre de partenaires
un certain nombre de d'entités en son
sein qui peuvent à un moment donné le
laisser croire à certains états de
l'union européenne comme aujourd'hui la
pologne qu'il pourrait perdre un petit
peu leur ce qu'ils appellent leur
souveraineté
de gestion de leurs frontières donc oui
frontex bien sûr mais pas ce n'est pas
qu'une question de moyens c'est une
question aussi de structures de nos
institutions européennes et moi je
regrette infiniment que la présidence de
l'union européenne la présidence
française qui va démarrer au 1er janvier
se télescope avec nos élections ici en
france parce que je ne vois pas comment
nous allons pouvoir porter cette voix de
la france sur des sujets comme celui
qu'on vient d'évoquer on est très
important oui parce qu'on saura nous
totalement phagocyté par nos élections
en interne et donc je trouve que le
président macron aurait dû accepter la
proposition qui lui avait été faite
c'est à dire de reporter une autre date
la présidence de l'union européenne pour
la france de manière à ce que cette
présidence la six mois ce n'est pas rien
puisse être réellement effectif pour la
france mais aussi pour l'union
européenne dans son ensemble
la pologne va construire un mur pour en
revenir à l'association polonaise d'un
montant de 353 millions d'euros pour
protéger sa frontière à la présidente de
la commission ursula von der leyen elle
s'opposait à la construction de ce mur
charles michel le président du conseil
européen lui était plutôt favorable
alors selon vous l'union européenne
doit-elle aider à la construction de ce
mur en pologne à titre très personnel là
je ne parle pas en tant que membre de la
commission des affaires européennes à
titre personnel je pense que ce serait
un très mauvais signal que nous
enverrons à construire un tel mur sur le
continent repères sur la jeunesse enfin
pour finir cette émission la majorité
présidentielle a lancé ce qu'elle
appelle le contrat d'engagement gêne
pour les moins de 26 ans sans formation
ni emploi depuis plusieurs mois ils
pourront prétendre désormais à une
allocation pouvant aller jusqu'à 500
euros par mois en échange d'un programme
d'accompagnement de 15 heures à 20
heures par semaine minimum une mesuré
qui aident à qui vise à aider les jeunes
les plus touchés par la sortie de la
crise sanitaire alors vous en tant que
présidente d'une mission locale est-ce
que déjà vous avez compris 1peler les
moyens d'accompagnement de ce contrat et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors là
encore ça fait partie d'une annonce qui
n'en est pas une il n'y a rien de
nouveau dans ce que le président a
annoncé à travers cela puisqu'il existe
un dispositif qui aujourd'hui est suivi
par les missions locales en france qui
s'appelle la garantie jeunes c'est
exactement la définition que vous venez
d'en faire or la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui que va devenir cette
garantie jeunes qui fonctionne très bien
vous savez on avait eu le dispositif un
jeune une solution dont on a eu la
relance et aidera donc il ya un certain
nombre de déjà deux mesures qui existent
et qui nous permettent d'aller